He owned up to it.
He goes,
"I've been a bad friend.
"I've been distant,
and I'm sorry.
"And I want to
make it up to you.
"So I got some mushrooms,
"and I think
we should do these mushrooms
to rekindle
our friendship."
[exciting music]
♪
[cheers and applause]
(Ari)
Thank you.
On this show,
here's what happens.
It's just a bunch of comics
telling true stories,
and that's all it is.
And to tell you
what happened to Pete Carboni,
ladies and gentlemen,
his side of the story,
Mr. Pete Carboni,
everybody.
Let him hear it.
[cheers and applause]
So it was about halfway
through the trailer...
[laughter]
To the movie Bruno
that I started
to feel sadder
than I've ever felt
in my life before.
I think what was
going through my mind is,
I was laughing
at the trailer.
I found it really funny,
and I was like,
"Yeah, this guy Sacha Baron
Cohen's a really funny dude.
He's doing really well
in his career," you know?
And then I started to think
of my own career as a comedian,
and I started to get
a little bit sad.
And that thought just
spiraled me
and propelled me
out of that room.
I had that feeling
that you have,
like, right before you're about
to cry hysterically.
I mean, am I right, fellas?
Yeah?
And I was in a dark place
in my life.
I'd just gotten out of this
on-again, off-again
embattled relationship
with this girl Kelly.
And Kelly would use
the off-again portion
of our relationship
to have sex
with some of my friends.
Yes, and this would
often inspire me
to take her back again,
you know,
to stop that
from happening,
which would make us
more embattled, you know?
Which would make me
break up with her.
The whole thing--it's what
an economist might call
a vicious cycle.
So I--like, I got to get
out of here.
I'm just not
in a good place.
So I jump into a cab,
and I say, "551 Sawtelle,"
'cause that's
where I lived,
and the guy must have
misheard me.
So he turned around,
and he was like,
"Uh, which hotel?"
And normally,
I think I would be able to
resolve this misunderstanding.
But in the condition I was in,
all I could think to do was,
I pointed in the direction
of my apartment,
and I just was like, "Go!
Please, just go!"
And so the guy just starts
driving in that direction,
and I'm like,
"Okay, I'm on my way home,"
and then we got
to a stop sign.
And it's a weird thing.
When you're on mushrooms,
it messes with your sense
of time, you know?
So it felt like I was at this
stop sign for, like, a year.
It felt awful.
And so I couldn't help my--
and I just start going,
"Go!
Please!
Please go!
Just go!"
And then the guy
would drive faster,
and then he'd get
to the next stoplight sooner.
And then I'd yell "go" again.
I mean, this is another
vicious cycle
I found myself in.
Until finally,
I felt so bad.
I felt like--"Geez, I'm"--
I'm like,
"This guy's, like,
a working-class guy.
He's doing his job
to support his family."
I'm like
this degenerate.
I'm doing mushrooms
on a Monday morning.
So I got out of the cab.
I told him to stop, got out.
And I gave him 100 bucks.
And then I turned,
and I just started running.
And I was running down
Bundy Avenue,
which if you don't know is
basically a four-lane highway.
And it's probably too big
of a street to be running down,
dressed like this,
as fast as you can
while you're crying
hysterically,
because people started
slowing down on the road
to check me out,
you know?
They're, like,
"Yeah, I don't think that guy
is jogging."
So I start to feel
really self-conscious,
and as I'm running,
I notice ahead of me
a hole, like,
in a fence.
And so my instinct is just to go
through this hole in the fence.
So I just jumped--
I sort of slide through,
and I wind up in,
like, this suburban backyard.
And there's some dude
who's, like,
reading a paper
on his back porch
as I come in
in my sad state.
And I was like, "I'm just...
I'm gonna try
the honesty approach."
I walk up to the guy.
I'm like,
"Uh, excuse me, sir?
"I'm very sorry,
but I'm feeling very sick.
Do you think that maybe
you could drive me home?"
And shockingly,
this guy says yes.
I was like--and my mind
was blown that he said yes.
I was like, "What a wonderful
world we live in
that this guy
would say yes to me."
I was like, "But he shouldn't,"
and he did,
and I love that man.
And we got in his car,
and, you know,
he starts driving,
but then he gets to a stop sign.
And I'm just out of control.
I'm like,
"Man, just go!
Please!
Just go!"
And we wind up
doing that again,
and then I finally tell him
to stop.
And I jump out of his car,
and I throw $200 at him.
And he--he says to me.
He's like, "Man, I just
drove you, like, five blocks.
It's really"--
And I was like, "Just take it!"
And then
I just started running.
And I ran
all the way home.
And when I got home, I started
to feel a little bit lonely,
and I started to rethink things
with Kelly, you know?
It's like,
you know, yeah,
she slept with a few
of my friends.
Okay.
Maybe I can
just take that as,
she finds my friends
really charming and attractive.
In a way,
that's like a compliment.
So I called her,
and I asked her to come over,
and she did.
And when she got there,
I begged her to take me back,
and she did.
And then my phone rang,
and it was Ari.
I was like, "Oh, yeah.
That's right.
"Like, we were supposed to be
doing mushrooms today
"to rekindle
our friendship
because I've been
such a bad friend."
And, Ari, do you remember
what you said?
(Ari)
Yeah, I was worried about you.
So I was like--I was like,
"Hey, are you okay?"
Yeah, and I thought
he was gonna attack me,
which would've been
the right thing to do.
And then I was like,
"You know"--
I don't know
how to tell him this,
so I was like, "Yeah, I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm here with Kelly."
Yeah, I forgot
about that.
You were like,
"I'm here with Kelly.
We got back together,"
but I was like...
[sighs]
"All right, well,
at least you're all right."
(Pete)
Yeah, he was
a good sport about it.
And then you--not only that,
then he says to me.
He's like, "Hey, man,
I just want to let you know
that I love you."
(Ari)
I do.
I was really concerned
for you.
Yeah, and I was, like,
overwhelmed with--
I was like--
That was so nice of you.
- Yeah.
I wouldn't have been
that way.
Let me ask you
a question.
(Pete)
What's that?
Why--why did you have
$300 on you?
[laughter and applause]
I think I figured that
I was doing something
sort of adventurous
that, like,
I should probably bring
emergency funds.
- You know?
- No, it's--
Just to be safe.
You don't need emergency funds
for a mushroom trip.
Oh, yeah,
but didn't I need them?
[laughter]
Wouldn't you say
that I needed them?
Yeah, you're right.
You're right, you did.
And I'm glad
you're safe, man.
I'm glad you're safe
as well.
Thanks.
Pete Carboni, everybody.
Pete Carboni.